auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
marina mara und micro stettler eröffnen
ihren waffel shop in tampa
die begeisterung ist groß die
arbeitstage sind lang 14 stunden pro tag
sieben tage die woche sind die regel
[Musik]
zuverlässig sind und ja ihr spiel ist
einfach
stress
viel arbeit auch in frankreich auf dem
riesigen hof der bauernfamilie visa die
mehr saison ist angebrochen
oft beim papa ist söhnchen
wegen corona hat der achtjährige
vorgezogene ferien
wir sind das dreamteam
sie sich nicht schwere wohl
ein leben in bereit daher
eva dunkle und philips weiter matti
haben in der toskana ein agriturismo
übernommen die italienische variante von
ferien auf dem bauernhof
einst waren die beiden ein liebespaar
nun sind sie geschäftspartner
die finanzierung unerwartete ausgaben in
zwei die beiden immer mehr philipp
möchte einen geschäfts kredit aufnehmen
ifa wir lieber in kleinen schritten
eigenes geld investieren
es bringt mir meinen bruder machen damit
wasser und bauen nicht so schlimm von
den banken bin ich das für mich den
hohen stress
[Musik]
schon in den frühen morgenstunden ist es
heiss der ferragosto italiens
sommerferien sind angebrochen
das ist
bitter so lustig und egal ob bei kuss
der gästebetrieb des aki turismo ist
überraschend schnell angelaufen
[Musik]
die stücke student wo kurz weiter
kaum haben die italienerinnen das tor
passiert kommt die nächste anfrage
bene ist sein ok nun schneller cucina
der encore in caracas ein
problem
aber irgendwie ist auf und das finde ich
super 8
wenn nur dieser schwelende konflikt
nicht wäre die beiden sind sich nicht
einig über ausrichtung und finanzierung
des betriebs
[Musik]
sicher ist sie müssen mehr land urbar
machen und auch das wird kosten
ackerbau eine komplett neue aufgabe für
eva
und
ich
bin sicher ich bin laden zum eigentlich
schaffen und lehre das ist so
trotz pensionsalter einfach nichts tun
das wird es für eva wohl nie geben
[Musik]
tampa das grand plaza shoppingcenter
hier ist der waffel shop der florida
auswanderer
[Musik]
monatelang hatten marina und mike seite
an seite gearbeitet mit erfolg das
geschäft boomt
doch nun von einem tag auf den anderen
steht marina allein im geschäft
100 stunden in der woche ohne einen
einzigen freien tag schuften und dies
während monaten
mike hatte einen zusammenbruch wie aus
dem nichts hatte er eines tages
panikattacken und fühlte sich schwach
stock sagte der arzt die ist seien erste
anzeichen eines burnouts
er verordnete ihm ruhe und medikamente
seit tagen ist er nun daheim
jetzt doch im kraftfahrzeug
stopp zuviel des guten
das heißt der blutdruck ist ob sie
massive ob sie
ja dann im dorf von mir sein können und
das geht so verknüpft dass sie auch der
heimklub letzten vier zu tag und
geführte heimdebakel
schachteln füllen und immer wieder eine
pause einlegen das geht
denn bald schon werden die beiden auch
noch umziehen
[Musik]
im waffel shop trägt marina die
verantwortung nun allein
zuverlässiges personal zu finden ist
nach wie vor schwierig
[Musik]
megi ist studentin sie unterstützt
marina so oft sie kann
noch ist völlig unklar wie lange mike
ausfallen wird
[Musik]
ihr partner fehlt einfach überall
ich hoffe
nur mit
der
vierten
nacht arbeitet
ja
[Musik]
in frankreich gehören die visas zu den
größten milchproduzenten der gegend
die molkerei be very much go list
abnehmer ihrer milch
viele
der 15 wichtigsten
also in der schweiz entwickelten joghurt
gasse wann dann nur stichfest tokio du
bist die einzige uni kassel haben und
das ist sie wirklich
[Musik]
täglich liefern die visa 6000 liter
milch nach maß cool
mindestens einmal in der woche kaufte
alexandra hier ein als zulieferer hat
sie 20 prozent
[Musik]
es wird aus vorhang nacht mega cool
in einem drittel aller produkte hier
steckt die milch der schweizer
auswanderer
[Musik]
zurück zum hof lesung
visas füttern die tiere hauptsächlich
mit mais und gras
[Musik]
angestellte hilfskräfte und bauern aus
der gegend unterstützen sandro wieser in
den sommermonaten macht er vier schnitte
von der landwirtschaftlichen kooperative
hat er einen häcksler zu gemietet
doch plötzlich steht alles still
eine panne wurde mail rausgeht
sitzt
axel pawlik ist viel energie
gestiegen
nichts geht mehr
der kaputte häcksler blockiert die
arbeit von vier fahrern samt traktoren
[Musik]
diese geschäfte
alle drei an
dass sandro ratlos ist kommt selten vor
er ist einer der sich eigentlich immer
irgendwie zu helfen weiß
auch sandras mitarbeiter wissen nicht
weiter
ein ersatz muss her
schnellstmöglich
das heißt wir da wieder mitgemacht
der sport ist er nicht genau beachten
das lied organisiert wo stunde lang
stillständen bevorsteht
[Musik]
und trage in der toskana es ist stickig
heiß
[Musik]
ein laues lüftchen wird zum sternchen
und gibt hoffnung
jetzt noch groß
trotz einiger schwerer tropfen fehlalarm
wieder kein gewitter wieder kein regen
und dies seit wochen schon
drückend wie das wetter ist auch die
stimmung bei den zürchern
philipp und eva müssen grundlegende
entscheide fällen ein konsens scheint in
weiter ferne ein eklat gar unabwendbar
doch heute will ifa keine probleme
wälzen sie ist voller vorfreude eine
tochter mit den enkelkindern reist an
ihre familie war ein wichtiger grund für
den kauf des gutes es soll auch ein hort
für ihre liebsten werden das ist so
vergangen
wie sterben die mama gefühle
bestimmen
das coni okay
ich bin sicher dass gott nicht
das ist ein job fürs leben
doch dass ich sie kommt auch zum hier
und
schon sind sie da
[Musik]
achtung achtung
hast du so gut
wie sieht ihr salon vorbei teneriffa
ist eine richtige clan chefin sie hat
vier töchter
drei söhne und acht enkelkinder
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so vieles gibt es für die enkel zu
entdecken im agriturismo diana
[Musik]
und 4
eschenlohr co
[Musik]
siegel termin in tampa
für mike ein besonders wichtiger moment
er verspricht sich viel von diesem umzug
[Musik]
das ist ein wertvolles stück der korpus
mit seinen tätowierten sie liehen ein
abschiedsgeschenk von schweizer freundin
marie hofft irgendwann wieder tätowieren
zu können
doch das ist im moment kein thema der
berner fühlt sich noch nicht gesund und
braucht immer wieder momente der ruhe
bye bye kartentel place ein neues
kapitel der florida auswanderer kann
beginnen
souverän
auf nach torchance springs
[Musik]
das neue heim liegt weiter nördlich und
ist ein vorort von tampa
ein kleiner wald liegt direkt vor ihrer
haustüre
hier ist alles noch ein wenig wilder
[Musik]
mehr von der natur umgeben darauf freuen
sich alle drei
freunde haben ihnen das haus vermittelt
kaum eingezogen treffen sie bereits
nachbarn
hier
[Musik]
in frankreich ging es schneller als
befürchtet nach 30 minuten schon stand
ein ersatz häcksler auf dem feld es
dauert nicht bis mitternacht aber dunkel
ist es allemal bis die maschinen endlich
still stehen sandro wieser ist geschafft
noch mehr aber ist er stolz
dreimal den betrieben der schweiz
na prima
aber schönes mitmachen will sich nicht
so
schnell gewöhnt in eine dimension ein
graffiti ihre das große spezifische
das notwendig so sind heute meist recht
fordern
zu wenig
für den schweizer bauern ist es wichtig
seinen tieren genügend gras verfüttern
zu können denn das ist proteinhaltige
als mais
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen ab und frankreich
in der schweiz hatte sandro gut 300
tonnen grassilage hier sind es fünfmal
so viel nebst 4000 tonnen mais
[Musik]
fr
ja
dünner
pauli
neue habe
[Musik]
die
die nacht ist kurz
die suppe ist kein kleiner bauernhof wie
in die visa sind der schweiz hatten
sondern ein großes unternehmen
vor kurzem haben die visa seine
zusätzliche tierwohl kontrolle bestanden
die stadt die etwa nie mal ist ein label
welches die molkerei von den bauern
verlangt
[Musik]
ja
wenn wir zwei und krieg als total
überlegen wobei vier und sagt hier wo in
betrieb sind das dass es noch mal ein
auto für mich an der haltestelle
behalten
wie stehen sie zu definieren
das ist das ist
das ist existenzgrundlagen jedermann
sehr sehr sorgfältig mit jener der
existenzgrundlage
um den nachwuchs ihrer tiere kümmert
sich alexandra
fast jeden zweiten tag kommt auf leser
je ein junges zur welt momentan sind es
60 kälber jedes bekommt sechs liter
milch am tag gefüttert das macht die
kleinen stark und für alexandra gibt es
muskeln
er braucht extrem kraft aufnehmen
rostocks die lehrkraft
schön
spree sagte
schaaf achtung crew
noch schleppt sie die schweren können
selber das taxi hat sie erst bestellt
mit diesem elektrischen milchwagen wird
die fütterung der kälber einfacher
werden
handling mit mit 200 schauen dass er
durchaus mit der sache wie bei allem
sinn vor 15 stunden im stau will ich
mich sicherlich nicht der fall opel
versorgt und die spieler betrifft
so wenige möglichkeit
wirtschaftskammer wenn ich weiß genau
wie viel
zu schlecht und meine das nicht weiß
jeder tag den
die cholera
bei visa ist ein nüchterner unternehmer
und rechner
doch zahlen kosten marge hin oder her
[Musik]
alexandra nimmt sich trotzdem zeit zum
bbi babel besonders mit den rindern die
sie aus der schweiz mitgenommen haben
[Musik]
torben spring in tampa der neue wohnsitz
der florida auswanderer
ihr zuhause liegt gut 30 minuten
entfernt von ihrem geschäft
ein klacks für us verhältnisse
noch immer bleibt mike daheim noch immer
fühlt er sich nicht kräftig
wieder seele noch körperlich
ihn plagen schwindel und kopfschmerzen
und sein nacken ist verspannt dass ihm
das atmen immer wieder mühe bereitet
[Musik]
wie lange geht das noch
wie lange muss marina den waffel laden
alleine managen
auch sie hat erste
ermüdungserscheinungen
glauben in dänemark beim 18 und das ist
seit gut einem jahr ist die ehemalige
product managerin eigenständige
unternehmerinnen und als solche hat sie
zusammen mit partner mai keine
entscheidung getroffen
gestern mittwoch in mannheim mit dem
franchise kaputtes nur abgesprochen will
muss also mit in absprache und
sie
extrem verständnis zeigt
aber wenn es dieses business nach
monatelangem schuften endlich ein fixer
gemeinsamer frei der tag
[Musik]
schon in den frühen morgenstunden
herrscht reger betrieb im agriturismo
klein und groß sind begeistert vom gut
ja
und helfen mit es herzurichten
[Musik]
eva ist froh um die unterstützung
bald schon kommen weitere gäste an noch
ist nicht alles perfekt und die
auswanderer haben schließlich hohe
ansprüche an die eigene gastfreundschaft
vorher muss ich danach
besuchen und ich hoffe
dass sie können zum beispiel einen kopf
machen oder so
yao
lifa hatte schon früh in liegenschaften
investiert sieben häuser hat sie in der
schweiz umgebaut
mannschaftskapitän diene man muss nicht
werk zusammen geschafft
die frauen haben übernommen
und so schlimmer des tunnels stecken
aber dann ersetzen
dabei war es eigentlich philipp der tags
zuvor begonnen hatte die vorhang stange
zu montieren
es ist nicht ganz einfach teil dieses
eingeschworenen bauteams zu werden
philipp wollte mitarbeitern die pfosten
um den pool setzen doch das hat nicht
geklappt
er kann es nicht lassen bei den frauen
vorbei zu schauen
endlich bist einfach es nicht darum dass
ich das nicht kann sondern dass das
jetzt gegen die besonders muss machen
ich weiß nicht was du in der pds
millionen zusammen machen den abzogen
abflug nur schlechterer nicht zeit und
ewigkeit titelt absolviert ja wie magda
posten aber jetzt ist nie passiert
nachdem
das gewitter ist da zu viele
missverständnisse und latente
unstimmigkeiten
[Musik]
es ist kühl hat sich ein das ganze reich
damit auch gut so es ist noch heuer in
die spannen sich auch alles mache ich
mir eigentlich wirklich
langsam
nicht dass derartig dass ich sehe dass
es mir wirklich nicht gut tut und
du das wirklich hinter aber bringen und
unsere leute
die ihre nachhaltigkeit hat ich muss dir
irgendwann nochmal entscheid ob du
kolonie wurde mache für ihn sind
oder ob du
irgendwie bis
wirtschaftet oder zu stärken die
schönste macht da
ich meine dusche
rückbindung
gestellt
[Musik]
die situation zwischen den beiden ist
komplett verfahren
die zwei sind für das bin ja ich
will mir einfach nicht ich brauche ganz
viele sachen das waren da die beete
ansicht über kronau über politik über
und somit einfach wirklich
die ganz wenig sachen wo mir ein ort
wirklich und sage
da stimmen wir überein
die fehler sodass sie jedoch noch das
ist
mit viel mut und herzblut sind die
beiden zürcher das projekt angegangen
beide hängen daran wollen es weiter
ziehen doch werden sie es gemeinsam
schaffen
[Musik]
in frankreich bei den visa es gibt es
heute die amis das lieblings bisher von
johns schwester dona die korona pandemie
hatte das reisen nach frankreich
verunmöglicht nach fünf langen monaten
kommt ja endlich zu besuch
ob sie das nehmen die drei mal im monat
zwei monate überprüfen wir befürchten
damit
ich eigentlich schon runter stand aber
eben
es ist heute so ich habe freude umso
größer wenn sie jetzt in litauen
knies amputiert
kaum war die schweiz nicht mehr auf der
risikoliste der franzosen kaufte sandro
der tochter ein flugticket
[Musik]
aber das berner löst sie will
das pflügen gemacht
fraktion wir aus guten bleistiften
träumen mit recht von der familie
steht nur ein irgendwie frank rostek auf
eine französische
mannschaft los
sweeney todd elik mir schöne patrick ist
über die
und dann kommt es als meine und das ist
richtig und dann noch eines der mädels
sagt
alexandra ist anpassungsfähig das und
die lust sich auf eine neue lebensart
einzulassen kommen ihr als auswanderer
nun zugute
sagt sagen und am besten 24 stunden sind
der knesset jede die krise des für jede
so schön wieder eine funktion
[Musik]
dafür mit nachbarstädten rolle frauen im
garten und trinken das wäre ganz lustig
neun monate 2008
[Musik]
zehn tage bleibt die 20 jährige jana
dann wird jeden moment mit ihr genießen
[Musik]
in tampa hat nike einen wichtigen termin
eine behandlung beim chiropraktiker
kann der therapeut mikes körperliches
leiden lindern
die da gemacht da
stressbedingt vorbei war kein sport mehr
gemacht
jetzt komme ich nach stockers 12 und 10
stimme doch
und mache also das eigentlich nach
wochen wieder auf geschaffen
also auch von mit dem problem dass hier
lockerer wird und dass man stress zu
reduzieren ist im
lässig muss niemand ist es ganz einfach
lee
umkrempeln
die beiden müssen wohl grundlegend etwas
ändern
dem geschäftigen alltag ein bisschen
freizeit abtrotzen und sich eine pause
gönnen das ist zumindest ein anfang
ich verspreche
die tampa bay area ist eine gegend mit
süßwasser sehen und vielen romantischen
plätzchen
was ich so stehen
wir stehen christoph
[Gelächter]
die bewegungen und stärkt
[Musik]
das ist kein arzt
doch genießen und abschalten ist
einfacher gesagt als getan
[Musik]
das ist
business und
keine pause für marina und mike in der
nächsten folge sind sie zu einem dessert
festival eingeladen es war natürlich
aber kurz vor der veranstaltung wird
marina krank muss 1000 waffel herzen
alleine packen
moment ist einfach eine person wallace
blockiert
in der toskana gehen sich philipp und
ifa zunehmend aus dem weg das projekt
kommt zum stillstand
eva entscheidet sich das agriturismo zu
verkaufen er
angekündigt dass er als kläger machen
und dann macht es funktioniert nicht
für ausflüge an den strand bleibt dieses
wenig zeit
[Applaus]
sie investieren viel zeit geld und in
die technik jedes rufes günstigste
das nicht immer zur freude der
angestellten die abläufe sondern muss
ihnen zwischen rückruf brachen dass man
wieder einen schritt nach vorne
trainerin muss nicht egal sind
so kommen
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge